der Tag nach der Wahl in presscode
Arizona ist grau und trüb die Stimmung
im Lohnsburg Café entsprechend guten
Morgen Jungs wir sind am Arsch diese
republikanischen Herren treffen sich
hier jeden Morgen das Thema heute der
Ausgang der mittirmes
wir haben nicht die überragenden
Ergebnisse bekommen die wir erhofft
hatten trotz der wirtschaftlichen Lage
die
Zurückweisung der beiden Regierung hat
nicht so stattgefunden wie erwartet
das ist ein wenig überraschend
es scheint dass wir in diesem Land
polarisierter sind denn je
ein paar Tage davor ein paar Kilometer
weiter die beiden Demokraten Jay Ruby
und Mike Vogel geben noch einmal alles
um in Java Pike Stimmen zu gewinnen
sie ziehen von Haus zu Haus um im
Gespräch für ihre Politik zu werben und
um in diesem erzkonservativen Bezirk
Vorurteile gegen Demokraten abzubauen
die meisten Demokraten in javapal County
werden von Sendern wie Fox News negativ
stigmatisiert wenn sie uns treffen dann
bekommen Sie ein anderes Bild
Mike Vogel früher Lehrer jetzt Rentner
und Kandidat für den Senatssitz in
Arizona seine Aussichten gleich Null und
doch gab er in diesem Rennen alles denn
jede Stimme zählt
[Musik]
sollten wahlleugner Schlüsselpositionen
bekommen wie das Gouverneurs Amt oder
dass das Innenministers von Arizona der
für die Wahlen zuständig ist dann ist es
sehr wahrscheinlich dass unsere Wahlen
künftig untergraben werden die
Republikaner haben diese Absicht sehr
deutlich geäußert
Jay und Mike erlebten bei ihrer Tour
durch javapi County eine aggressive
Grundstimmung die Fronten zwischen
Republikanern wie Ruben Thompson und
Demokraten wie Diane powers sind
verhärtet die Gräben scheinbar
unüberwindbar die Nachbarn sprechen
schon seit langem nicht mehr miteinander
[Musik]
die Republikaner wollen alle Rechte
abschaffen die wir uns in den letzten
Jahren so hart erkämpft haben vom Recht
auf Abtreibung Rechte für Homosexuelle
und für schwarze sie wollen uns das
alles wieder wegnehmen
die Demokraten haben nichts richtig
gemacht was meinen Sie damit was sollte
besser werden ich möchte dass beiden und
seine ganze Administration sein
Justizministerium der Chef des FBI alle
nach Alaska auf ein Eisberg geschickt
werden
er ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür was in
unserem Land los ist wir sind extrem
gespalten die Republikaner gegen die
Demokraten es ist verrückt ich kann
nicht glauben wie zerrissen dieses Land
inzwischen ist ich schäme mich momentan
eine Amerikanerin zu sein
während Jay und Maike um jede Stimme für
die Demokraten kämpften bereiteten sie
sich nebenan schon auf das Schlimmste
vor verwette dein Arsch darauf es gibt
Bürgerkrieg bürgerkrie so die düstere
Prognose der aus Keepers einer
extremistischen Gruppierung die der
festen Überzeugung ist dass Donald Trump
die Wahl gestohlen wurde und die
Demokraten ihr Land und ihre Verfassung
bedrohen
Einladung ich glaube nicht nur dass es
in Amerika einen Bürgerkrieg geben wird
ich bin der Überzeugung dass wir mitten
drin sind Bürgerkriege entstehen nicht
über Nacht sie entwickeln sich
allmählich aus politischer und
wirtschaftlicher Instabilität
solche extremen Ansichten wie die der
oldkeepers sind hier keine
Randerscheinung im Gegenteil viele
Republikaner in Arizona teilen Sie die
Partei ist tief gespalten
moderate Partei Mitglieder wie Ken
Bennet gibt es immer weniger noch rarer
sind treffen wie dieses zwischen ihm und
einem Demokraten wie Mike Bewerber um
das gleiche Amt
wir sind Rivalen ja aber freundliche
Rivalen die beiden schätzen sich weil es
in ihrem Wahlkampf um Themen ging und
nicht um Hetze gegen den Gegner Ken ist
damit in seiner Partei ein Außenseiter
es macht mich traurig dass die
republikanische Partei gerade so
gespalten ist aber ich glaube dass wir
das wieder hinbekommen ich glaube auf
lange Sicht gesehen werden konservative
ideale Siegen
he is on the play the er hat hier ein
bisschen untertrieben uns droht eine
Krise
wenn die radikalen republikanischen
Kandidaten bei dieser Wahl alle
Schlüsselpositionen gewinnen
dann wird die Bedrohung größer
denn dann wird Arizona im Jahr 2024 der
Mittelpunkt einer sehr umstrittenen
Präsidentschaftswahl
das sind die republikanischen
Kandidatinnen Kandidaten von Arizona
letzte Wahlkampfveranstaltung sie machen
Stimmung mit den üblichen hässlichen
Parolen über die Demokraten die das Land
in den Untergang treiben und Trump die
Wahl gestohlen haben
sie ist der neue Shootingstar der
Republikaner die ehemalige
Fernsehmoderatorin Cary Lake ist
leidenschaftliche trump-anhängerin und
fest davon überzeugt dass ihm vor zwei
Jahren die Wahl gestohlen wurde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie wollen dass wir glauben dass beiden
81 Millionen Stimmen bekommen hat
beleidigt nicht unsere Intelligenz
wenn ich Gouverneurin bin werden wir das
Wahlsystem reformieren und wieder faire
und transparente Wahlen einführen
noch ungewiss doch jetzt schon hat sie
Zweifel am Wahlergebnis geäußert
mike hat das Rennen um den Senatssitz in
Arizona wie erwartet verloren doch als
Verlierer sieht er sich und seine
Demokraten nicht
perfecting
wir nehmen Einfluss auf den Diskurs
wir sind eine Kraft für den Wandel und
der ist noch möglich
da bin ich hoffnungsvoll
Jay und Mike haben es geschafft den
javapi County viele Wählerinnen und
Wähler für die Demokraten zu
mobilisieren dennoch haben sie Sorge
dass in diesem aufgeheizten Klima ihr
Politikstil immer seltener werden könnte